à cluny la manifestation hippique de ce
week end a failli tourner au drame
car ce bâtiment de plus de 700 mètres
carrés situé en plein coeur des
installations sportives a été ravagé par
les flammes
un incendie accidentel ce sont deux
enfants qui ont été à l'origine de celle
de ce feu
qui s'est déclenchée extrêmement vite
qu'on n'a pas pu nous
se mettre en action la suze pour ça qu
on a appelé les pompiers immédiatement
parce que c'est parti à moustey ce grand
v et lorsque les premiers pompiers sont
arrivés sur place d'un 13h45
ils ont immédiatement demandé du renfort
car le feu était très violent compte
tenu notamment de la paille qui sert
habituellement pour les choses ma
priorité a été de stopper la propagation
à la forge et aux espaces de bureaux que
nous avons réussi à faire et donc à
limiter les dégâts
sachant que la carrière était vide et
donc seuls dommages sur la carrière
et la charpente qui elle est partie pour
pour moitié dans la santé au plus fort
de l'incendié le dispositif de secours
contrat jusqu'à 45 pompiers lourdement
équipé puisque 22 véhicules
d'intervention ont été déployés aucune
victime humaine ou animale n'est à
déplorer